fiorella LaGuardia is kind of the
villain of the piece why did LaGuardia
ban pinball yeah LaGuardia came in
definitely on a crusade to stop
organized crime which I think was a
laudable goal but it was very hard to do
and it's very hard to to show people
that he was succeeding
in 1933 fiorella LaGuardia ran for mayor
promising to rid New York City of
corruption and organized crime pinball
he said was gamble ruled by the mob a
racket to steal lunch money so keep
banned it you know for the children and
it wasn't just a band it was a public
relations Crusade major raids throughout
the city squads of police swarming into
bowling alleys bars anywhere they could
find them